one of the most interesting examples of
an engaged leader is when President
Obama decided to go on to reddit as part
of his presidential campaign in 2012 and
he held what is called and asked me
anything session so they announced he
was going to be on there and anybody
could ask any question of Obama what a
great opportunity right and so he
studiously SAT there and responded to
people and answer their questions except
he didn't the most popular and most
frequently asked question of Obama was
what do you think about the legalization
of marijuana and it was very clear so
evident and Obama wanted to have nothing
to do with that topic he just students
Lee kept ignoring that topic and
answering all the other questions that
were coming up so it's interesting that
you can ask me anything but I may not
necessarily answer you that relationship
was a bit tarnished for the people who
on that session because they quickly
realized he's not willing to truly
engage in the spirit of this he was
going to answer only the questions that
he wanted to if they knew anything about
the reddit audience they would have
known that have been the very top
question so as a leader when you're in
those situations when you're not ready a
better way to deal with that is it to be
very honest about that I'm not prepared
today to answer those questions and if
Obama had just said I hear all of you
asking you about the legalization of
marijuana I'm not ready to answer that
question today and these are the reasons
why be clear you set expectations but
what you were engaged on you may have it
worked out in your mind it's really
important to tell the people who are
really following you as a leader to tell
them what can they expect in that
engagement how far will you go in that
engagement to set those expectations
early on so that they're not
disappointed
you